[Music]
really the question is I suppose the
ultimate question is does consciousness
come first and/or does physical reality
come first or do they both come into
being together and of course we can't
ever know the answer because we couldn't
be there at the moment of the Big Bang
or before it to see the answer
so it's speculative and it's a matter of
belief either way what we have at the
moment is a dominant philosophy within
the Natural Sciences of philosophical
materialism which is the assumption
matter comes first and consciousness
emerges from matter in and as yet
unexplained way when brains get big
enough a kind of light bulb of
consciousness goes on but the
consciousness isn't actually anything
it's nothing it's either an Fe
phenomenon or it's an illusion that's
the materialist philosophy of mind so
consciousness itself is problematic it
ought not to exist we ought not be
conscious it's an embarrassment for
materialism that we are so if we take a
different view if we take consciousness
as primary then we get to a view held by
almost all religious traditions that
there's a consciousness comes first and
gives rise to a universe and this is not
just religious philosophical for Plato
you have a realm of ideas or forms that
comes first the Platonic he calls that
reality and then there's a kind of
emanation or for neoplatonism and a kind
of emanation from that realm to give the
physical universe so that's another way
of thinking about it now if it were just
a matter of arguing philosophically that
would be the end of the matter we
wouldn't be able to get anywhere but the
reason that religions exist is because
people have had mystical experiences
over the ages where people through
consciousness itself have felt that
their consciousness is linked to some
vastly greater consciousness than their
own which they identify as the ultimate
consciousness of the universe or God or
whatever name they choose to put to it
and now one could say well it doesn't
count as science but science
Lawrence Krauss emphasizes is based on
empirical facts and consciousness is the
ultimate empirical fact empirical means
based on experience and consciousness is
experience so the exploration of these
ultimate realities
I think involves mystical experience as
well as scientific measurements of the
cosmic microwave background radiation
and suchlike and when we take that into
account as well the conscious
explanation of reality then some kind of
fundamental role for consciousness
becomes important and is consciousness a
thing or is it not a thing I mean that's
another debate which they may have views
on I have four more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you